one of the cars that I used to really
like on that show he was this
long-haired uh like super flamboyant gay
guy he was standing with his back to me
and I get closer and I'm like oh my God
he's making out with somebody and he was
just making out with this dude like
after I walk up and I'm kind of getting
into the phone and he goes oh hey what's
up you know like oh nothing you know he
the other guy looks at me and goes uh
you're not GNA say anything about this
are you I was like no I don't know you I
don't whatever my Carney friend he goes
he's the uh local weather guy on the
news here
nah he's he outed him twice he outed him
twice he's gay and he's the local
weather
man the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
[Music]
today